sound check everybody okay
good morning my name is captain haas the
las vegas metropolitan police department
and i'm here to bring some awareness
to an increase in carjackings we've seen
here locally
as well as nationally this year we've
had 17 carjackings across our valley
and that's a number that's not
acceptable several of these have
resulted in arrest but we're seeing some
particular trends that are concerning to
us
most of these individuals that are doing
these carjackings involve juveniles
as young as age 14 and 15 years old
most recently we had a series of
carjackings occur
where three individuals were taken into
custody where they had done carjackings
every night on the 4th of february
the 5th of february and were caught on
the 6th of february
going to do another carjacking in the
area
three three of these people two of them
were juveniles again
that's not good for our valley we're
seeing this increase
nationally as well across the united
states
one things we have to do as a community
is get around these kids
they're not in school they've got a lot
of free time and metro's working with
intervention officers to get out there
and make contact with these kids before
they go down this road of violence
this road of gangs and destruction of
their lives
we need to make sure that we're getting
out there to get them the help they need
and the services they need that they
would usually get through school
district where it was identified early
that we're finding later
we've also found that these carjackings
are done by a small number of
individuals
out of the 17 we've had this year
already nine of them are related to
multiple events
that shows us there's a trend with these
certain people going out there and
committing these crimes
we've seen a lot of violence associated
with these carjackings
and the ones i talked about both a force
and firearms were used in both of those
events
that firearm was recovered and it was
determined to be a pellet gun
but you couldn't tell until close
inspection that it was a fake firearm or
not a real firearm
we've also seen a trend with vehicle
burglaries across the valley involving
juveniles
several of these crews of individuals
have been taken into custody
and they almost all involve juvenile
crimes so i need the community's help
don't make them easy victims make sure
we go out there we lock our cars
we don't have valuables stored in our
vehicles we're not storing
firearms in our vehicles it's important
that we stay safe and keep this
community safe
and if you see something in your
neighborhood that doesn't belong make
sure you call the police report it to us
whether to see something say something
3-1-1 or if it's in progress
9-1-1 it's imperative we work together
to solve these crimes if they go
unreported
i can't help with getting them solved or
stop them from happening in the first
place
is there any questions regarding this
series of crimes
could you talk about what what is sort
of bringing this on you talked
about it a little bit before but could
you expand on why do you think
what are you attributing what are you
attributing this rise in carjackings
and uh there's a lot of theories on what
could be causing this
some of it's social economic some of
it's just crime of opportunity and
that's typically what we've seen with
our suspects here locally
is they're looking for crimes of
opportunity at times both of the
carjackings that i was referring to
happened at one and four in the morning
at people at atm machines it's important
we're aware of our surroundings because
we don't want to be that target and we
can make ourselves not be victims by
being aware of our surroundings
and where do they where do they disperse
geographically geographically they're
all across the valley there's not one
area coming that's getting hit harder
than others
again this is crime of opportunity
they're looking for that
easy victim that's anywhere around the
valley it could be on the east side the
west side it doesn't matter
the reality is we have to be aware of
our surroundings and these kids that are
doing these crimes we have to find a way
to get them into some support networks
that are positive and give those
positive role models so they're not
going down this road of violence and
gangs to get these kids help
so every air command at metro has what's
called an intervention officer
and this isn't a one-time visit we're
doing with these kids this is a three
and four month follow-up with these
families
to bring the services around them that
they need to help them be successful not
just as
one individual is that that young man
that's doing these crimes
but the family as a whole if there's
other issues that are causing us we want
to get them addressed on the front end
so we don't have to complete this cycle
of arresting them putting them into the
criminal justice system
bringing him back out and having that
cycle repeat itself over and over again
we've got to break that
that cycle of crime with these
individuals and these young young men
and women of our society
to make sure they're getting that help
and support they need is there a
specific area that this is happening
more than in other areas i mean
is there sort of a focus that you guys
have i i wish i could say they were
happening in just one area but that's
just not the reality of it they're
happening all across the valley
why do you choose this area um i'm in
summerlin area command this is important
to me and this is why we're here um
carjackings happening here i've had one
happen in this area
why you chose this particular spot yes
so 17 car jacking
so far this year how does this compare
to previous years and of those
carjackings you know
what percentage would you say involve
juveniles
so about 50 percent involve juveniles
and we're at about a 30
increase in carjackings from last
of the year is there any indication that
they know each other that this is sort
of like a
ring of some kind every time we've
disrupted or arrested a group of these
individuals no matter where it's at we
don't find a lot of connection between
the suspects they are typically that the
suspects will reside in the same area
but they're traveling all over the
valley to commit these crimes
[Music]
so again we're back to this is a crime
of opportunity they're not they're not
looking for a specific car
type they're not looking for amounts of
money they're looking for that easy
target that
they can hit easily and get away quickly
social media played a factor in any of
these crimes or or looking into these
crimes
through the investigation not that i'm
aware of i appreciate your guys time
thank you so much and helping us keep
this valley safe
thank you
you